次に このパターンについてちょっと学んでみます
現象は来ている ちょっとこの花が邪魔して
ちょっと文字がちょっと読めないという具合もありますけど
パターンを無視できない
パターンというものは馬鹿にするんじゃないんです
それは無視できないんです
発見するしかないんです
はい 物質世界のパターン
これは皆様学んでいることだから
ちょっと詳しく説明します
科学とは物質のパターンを発見する分野です
簡単ですよ 科学は物質のパターンを発見するんです
普段わからないんです
考古学っていうのは 古い品物を現代発見しているパターンで説明することです
まあ穴を掘っていると
なんかこの炭になってる籾一個見つかる
まあ一個二つとかね それだけ
そうすると現代パターンは籾をなんて言いますか
で 米にしてご飯食べるんですね
人間が それでさっさと結論に至るんです
この当時で人間は米食べていましたよと堂々と語るんです
あの炭になった籾 2  3個見つけただけで
それは考古学なんです
本当に食べたのか知ったものじゃないんです
じゃあ考古学を本当どうでしょうかと思う分野もある
しっかりした工学は考古学もある
日本の場合は この感動的なところはすごく好きみたい
いわゆる嘘のところ 考古学者の人は言ってますよ
この本当に研究できるんかと
みんなこの感動するストーリーが欲しいんかったりするんだと
発明って何ですかというと
発見したパターンに合わせて新しいものを作ることですね
何か発見と言ったってもね
発明と言ったっても 何か世の中に新しいものが現れるわけじゃないんですよ
あのすでにあるパターンで何かを組み立てるんです
まあだから科学の例で言えばね
例えば地球に引力あったっていうことは
地球が現れた時からあったものですけど
あるのに発見できないんですね
そのパターンを そこである人が突然
あ こういうことではないかと
このパターンを発見するんです
そしてその人を科学者と言うんです
医学は体のパターンを発見するんです
体はどのようなパターンで動いているのかと発見することは医学ですよ
医学が発展あってもなくても
体はそのように動いてたんですよ
人間の心臓の中に穴が 4つあると
穴というか このチェンバーが 4つあったことは初めからもあったんですけど
でも そういう 4つがあって血液が流れてるんだという
そのパターンが後から発見するんですね
初めからあったパターンを
そうすると医学が発展しましたと
なんか人間に何かいいことになったような感じ
何もいいことになってないんです
論理学は物質のパターンから作る思考パターンです
この論理学というものがありますね
論理 数学などなど あれは物質を見て
で それからこの思考パターンを作るんですね
数学というのはほとんど考えることなんですね
実際の世界とそれほど関係ないんです
だからこの思考パターンを作るんです
現象は無限にあるから
発見するものは無限にあります
現象といえば 結構世の中で無限にありますよ
地球のことにしたっても
いまだ知らないことどれほどあるのかと
かなりありますよ まだまだ発見していない生命もいる可能性あります
それで終わらないんですよ
例えば植物のことなら
ほとんど地球のものは発見していますよ
といっても 植物もそのまま待っていないんですよ
変化するんですよ 変化しちゃって
まだわけもわからない新しい植物の種類がもう誕生したりするんだから
海の塩を研究しようとしたっても
まあどこでも同じ海の塩でしょうと
はい 研究終わった それがないんですよ
日々その性質変わっていくんだから
だからこのパターンというのは無数に無限にあります
だから発見するべきものも無数に無限にあります
だからパターンを発見することが学問であって
科学であって 医学であって
勉強であって知識なんですよ
だから増やそうと思えば
知識というものがもう無限に無限にあるということになるんです
パターンを正しく完全に発見しないで解説する
だから人間っていうのは一部わかっただけで
すっごい舞い上がっちゃって
それは堂々と発表するんです
我はこういうものを発見しましたとかね
世界はこうなってるんだとか
あのペニシリンを発見したところで
まあこれから人類は病気にかからないで済むでしょうと
すごいことを発見しましたと
あれってデータがほんのちょっと知っただけで言ったことで
ペニシリンでもう細菌がなくなるんだと
でも後で見てみたら全く違うんですね
ペニシリンに効くウイルスは一部で
効かないものもたくさんあると
それでペニシリンで効くものでも
体がペニシリンを受け入れるか受け入れないか
また問題がありまして
そうすると あのペニシリンがすごい玉座に座っていたんだけど
そこから降りて そこら辺の一般人の椅子に座る羽目になっちゃったんです
だからこのように科学の世界で
もう知識の世界で もう
かなり政権交代が起こるんです
毎日のように 後の人は新たなパターンを見つけて前の考えを訂正するんですね
いつでもこの世の中で
それで知識世界が増えていくんです
因果法則はパターンに対する仏教用語です
ただそれだけ言いたいんです
このパターンというのは
もう知識的に見れば無数にあるんです
だから知識っていうのは無数
無限 無限 なんですが だから知識を追っていく人はひどい目に遭うんですよ
無限というものを追っていこうとするんだからありえないんです
で 仏教はそういうものについて言ってるのは
これ因果法則という単語なんですね
因果法則 すべて因果法則であると
物質の因果法則 はい これから仏教の話に入ります
今までのことはまあよくわかっていることだから
皆様方はもうずっと子供の頃からね
年になってもいろんなことを勉強してるでしょうに
いくら学んでもきりがないでしょうに
ですから まあ仏教はその世界をどのように見ているかというと
因果法則として見ているんです
世間にこれについて驚くほどの成果を
世間はこれについてというのは
この物質の因果法則 物質の因果法則について世間が驚くほどの成果は出しています
もう 100年前と今の世界を見ると
もう信じられないほど変わっているんですね
一人の人間に人類が発見しているすべての知識
科学 芸術などを学ぶことは不可能です
世の中で驚くほどの知識があるんだけど
一人の人間には全部学ぶことは不可能です
能力があると仮に設定しても
人にもういろんなものを学ぶ能力があるんだと
ある何かなになにさんには
あの人にならもう何でも学べるぞと仮にしましょう
寿命は短いので時間が足りませんね
それでも 医学は学んで医学の一流のプロになって
それから高校 工学も学んで
工学の一流のエンジニアになるぞと
もう間に合わない もうピアニストにはなる暇がなくなるんです
だからそれを覚えておかないと全部学べないんです
ピアニストになろうと思ったら
一流の一生をそれにかけなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
また 一つの分野で天才能力を発揮しても
その分野で全てを知りました
それ以上知るべきことは存在しないと終了宣言はないんです
例えば ある天才が現れてきて
ある分野で研究をする
特に世の中で この論理性の天才と言われる人間は全部科学の世界に逮捕されますから
いろいろ分野でね 仕事をさせるでしょう
それでそういう人々はすべてわかったかというと
そうではないんです この物質の因果法則を発見する世界で
これが確実にありますよ
知り尽くしましたということは出てこないんです
一部知りましたと もしかすると新たなデータによってよって
この一生をかけて知った一部も違うかもしれませんと
かわいそうな状態なんです
これがいつでも知識世界である問題点なんですね
いくら学んでも 完成しないんです
未熟です 天才がいろんなことを研究して発表しても未熟です
あと 他の人が天才でもない人は
それはさらに研究して
あちら間違ってた こちら間違っていたという可能性はもういくらでもあるし
そんなことは日々起きているんですね
だから物質のパターンを学ぶことは世界がやっている知識世界です
科学世界です 技術世界です
この知識世界 科学世界
芸術世界 技術世界 すべていくらやっても未熟
その個人の立場から見ると個人が未熟なんです
で 全体的にまとめると結構発展しているかもしれませんだけど
だから一つの仕事をするときでも
いろんな分野の人をやたらはなくちゃいけないんですよ
病院見てみてください
いろんな専門家が集めているんです
一人でできないんです
はい 医者が薬決めますけど
やっぱり薬剤師も必要になっちゃうんです
外科が体は切るんだけど
いろんな分野のプロたちが囲まっていないと何もできない
だから現代医学で見事見事に手術できますよと言ばっても
あれは一人がやっていることじゃないんですね
例えば体をもう切るためにレーザー光線使ったりする
レーザー光線っていうのは種類がたくさんありますね
そこで医学と何にも関係ない電気関係の世界で
どこかの三菱やらあれやこれやと工場でもうもう何も体のことを何も知らん研究者たちがそれを開発しているんです
様々な種類のレーザー光線を
それ開発したんですけど
こんなでっかい機械はもうどうにもならんだから
それからいろんな外科の医学の世界の人々と話し合って
形はどうしますか？とかね
これだったらこのもう皮膚をそのまま置いといて
下の血管を切ることはできますよ
なんとかわかります そんなのはないんだけど
もうできますよとかね
だからそこで外科の先生が
あのね こんな 20 キロの機械はね
持って体に当てると もういろいろ擦れますよと
だからミリ単位で精巧に当てなくちゃあかんやと
私たちは手で物を重いものを持つことはダメですよと
ああ そうか それでまた
また工場でそこを考えて
もうやっと機械が出てくる
そこで手術室で医者がレーザー光線のメスを使っても
ものすごいたくさんの能力のある人々がかかってはいるんですね
だから現代私たちはそういう集合的な行動でなんとか生きているんですね
そういうところを観察すると
何か見えるかというと
一人一人は何の役にも立たない人々なんです
病院ですごい優秀な看護婦であっても
そこから取って他のところに取ってみると
何のも役に立たないものなんです
一流の世界一流の腕が上がっている外科かもしれませんだけど
あのスタッフとあの手術室と
その部品から外へ持ってきたら何もできないんです
それが知識世界のありさまなんです
だからどこまで立っても未熟です
未熟ですけど 本人が自分の一生をかけてますよ
この未熟な知識を身につくために
未熟な能力 力を身につくために一生研究して頑張っているんです
それでみんな協力してくれるならば
関係のある人々は何か役に立つ仕事はできます
関係の悪い人と協力してくれなかったら何もできない
それで大きなポイントは
これ仏教の見方だから
仏教の見方から見ると
大きなポイントはあなた方には永久的に終了宣言はできないんだよと
なんか無限に未熟でいるんだ
いる 無限に未熟にいる道ですと
ということです ですから
俗世間のパターンを学ぶ挑戦は終わりのない
満足に至らない 精神的に疲れ果てる作業です
だから世界の人間というのは終わりのない
満足に至らないことに挑戦しているんです
誰でも疲れ果てるんです
しかし これが人間の職業なので
それで生きてるんですよ
やめることもできないんです
大変です やってみても
どこまでやっても未熟で未熟でどうにもならん状態
じゃあやめましょうと言ったってやめられないんです
それで生きてるんだから
パターンを知らなかったらもうどうにもならんだから
それで仏教の話 ブッダも物質のパターンについて語ってます
しかし ブッダの語り方は違います
だから こんな不完全で不満で疲れ果てて知識にいる人々は
ブッダの見方を学ぶとたちまち落ち着くんです
完全な知恵も何なのかということを知って
それ得る方法もあります
で しかし ここからはね
仏教ではもう究極の難しいところにはなりますから
まあかなりごまかしておきます
真面目に説明しないことにします
1番目の単語はイダッパッチェーターという単語なんです
この現象は これによってこれが生じるという性質である
あります これは因縁性と言うんです
お釈迦様にとってはこのすべてまとめて理解するんですね
だから いかなる現象を見ても
あ これだ これがあって
これが生まれているんだ
これがあって これが生まれているんだ
それで逆に調べたら合っている
あ これがないとこれがないんだと
ということは これがこれの原因であると
ということで 一切の現象は因縁性持っているんだよと
ということは 科学であろうが
考古学であろうか 歴史で地理学で
何であろうとも 家族生活であろうとも
夫婦生活であろうとも
子育てであろうとも 政治であろうとも
経済学であろうとも 因縁性に成り立っているんだと
それでこの因縁性というものを学ぶんです
だからその知恵には世間はかなわないんです
具体的に何かならなきゃ学ぶんじゃないんです
因縁性を学ぶんです それはコンディショナリティというイダッパッチェータ 2
番目タタタ 全部因果法則の形容詞なんです
タタタというのはオブジェクティビティということで
で これは観察できる 発見できる
とても具体的な現象の性質という意味で
この訳するのすごい難しいんです
単純に言えば具体性 はっきりして具体性だ
この科学の場合も 具体性に欠けているのが結構あるんです
具体性あまりなく 医学もいろんなことをやっています
そうなってくるとパターンではなくて
自分の気持ちとか あるいは当ててみる
もしかするとそうなるんじゃない？とかね
あんた試しにこの薬飲んでみなさいとかね
そういうことが結構あるんです
で 釈尊がおっしゃるのは
この一切の物事にははっきりした
具体的にこれだからこうなる
これだからこうなるということはありません
次の言葉はアヴィタタタ
英語ではリアリティ この法則は事実であり
違ったことにならないという性質
この因果法則っていうのは事実であって絶対的です
変わりませんということ
次の言葉はアナンニョタタ
インベアリアビリティ
可能性 確率性ではないんです
仏教が言う仏質の話は確実性なんです
お釈迦様が現象のパターンをこのように発見しているんです
もうかなわない発見なんです
そういうことで お釈迦様の観察と現代人ではなくて
人間 科学者の観察には違いがあるんです
世間では一切の現象に普遍的に
確実に  また普遍的に 漢字が違いますけど
あの ある因縁性を発見する気持ちはなさそうです
この世の中の人々には
この普遍的な因縁性 発見しようということはないんですね
それから確実な因縁性
それから普遍的 いわゆる変わらない
因縁性を発見しようとしないんです
本当は因縁性なんですよ
みんなやっているのは
科学者も医学もちゃんと因果法則で頑張っています
が その因果法則はガタガタ
曖昧で中途半端で大したことはない
それで例を出したんで
例でわかりますよ リンゴの糖度を上げて
色を美しく 形を整えて
また長持ちできるように育てるのに必要な因縁は何かと観察する
それでその人の満足人は
まあそれは十分だと思っちゃいます
まあそれはまあたとえ話でリンゴを育てる人がいると
その人には世界はどうなっても
リンゴという植物はどんなものであっても
こんなのはどうでもいいんだけど
ただこのリンゴという実をもっと艶がある美しい色で
もっと形がしっかり丸めてあって
また糖度が上げて 作るためにはどうすればいいかと発見するんです
ちゃんと因果法則が発見しますよ
そういうふうに作りますから
皆様 比較したことがありますかね
日本のリンゴと外国のリンゴは
すっごく違うんです 日本のリンゴはもうもう九十五パーセントぐらい人工的なんです
自然にあったものじゃないんです
改良 改良 改良 改良 改良して
それで改良したものをあまり人間が好まなくなっちゃうと
平気で派手に宣伝して
そこがもうもうすごいクールだと
このリンゴはそういう風にもうそれに慣れてもらって
特別そうなリンゴを作っているんです
で なんか外国はオーストラリアとかニュージーランドとか
あるリンゴなんか並べておいたら
もう外国のリンゴは立場がなくて
格好悪くて惨めでかわいそうです
このリンゴはすごくなんかふじとか
なんか 1個何千もかかるリンゴもありますからね
味はよろしいし 歯触りがよろしいし
そこで日本でもう一つ特別な考え方があって
このものの味っていうのは二割なんです
八割は香りなんです 我々はすごく美味しいと言っても
本当は八割は香りで 喉と鼻の後ろで香りを感じて美味しいと思っちゃうんです
やはり香りはまるっきり感じない
何か特別風邪を引いたり
いろいろあったりすると
食べ物はまずいんです
体の事実はそうなんですけど
日本では香りは嫌がるんです
あれも事実 事実 事実ではというか
実際の肉体はそうじゃないんです
マインドコントロールされているんです
こんなひどい香り これは嫌よとかね
ですから 日本のリンゴにはそれほど香りが取った時ありますよ
取った時ありますけど
もうすぐ一日でそこ消えちゃうんです
それでスーパーマーケットで売っているものを売っているものには全く香りがないんです
だから本当はまずいんですけど
しかしマインドコントロールされているんだから
それが美味しいってことになるんです
だからこちらで大量の改良を開発していますけど
こちらの独特な思考パターンによって
そこをまた改良 改良方法が道が決めるんです
だからこの農業開発っていうのは世界で誰にでもできますよ
でも結構違いますから
世界ではこのリンゴにそこまで手がかかっているところはないんですね
それで日本にブドウも入ってくると
ブドウにもブドウさんも同じ運命になっちゃったんですね
世界でない自然では絶対あり得ないブドウしかないんです
で また人間がね あれも食べますから
イチゴもね またかわいそうで
自然にないイチゴを自然にないメロン
いろいろできたりする
はい それができたのはなぜでしょうかというと
そのその分野の因果法則なんです
そのその分野の因果法則を発見して
そこをいろいろいじって
いろんな因果組み立てて
パターンを いろんなパターンを組み立てて組み立てて
新しい品物を開発する
それからこのマインドコントロールはする
もう世の中でない自然なものでないものを作ると
普通は興奮するはずなんですね
怖いと で 興奮させないで
最初からもうマインドコントロールして落ち着いていくんです
もうバンバン咲いて喜べと
例えば遺伝子改良で大豆作ると
それにすごい文句を言うんです
大変だ 危険だとか 何知って言ってるんですかね
だったら日本のリンゴも食ってはいけませんしね
そういうならば  だからこの遺伝子改良
遺伝子組み換えで野菜やら米やら作ることに
大豆やらね 小麦粉とか小麦とかね
作ることでも 世界はこのマインドコントロール先にやっちゃったならばね
何も問題なかったと思いますけどね
あの 日本以外はもうそこマインドコントロールではなくて
この特許取って もうみんなの金独り占めにしてしてやるぞと欲が先に行くんですよ
だからそこは失敗するんです
日本ではあまり欲は先に出さないんですね
それで何か開発しても
あまりあの世界はものすごい判断
判断 判断 反対して攻撃して
研究は片っ端からもう役に立たないことにはならなくなっちゃう
そういうのは世間話でどうでもいいことで
私のポイントはそういうことじゃないんです
世間は因果法則を発見しないということなのよ
ポイントは だからリンゴを作る人にとっては
農家にとってはリンゴだけ美しくおいしくできれば十分です
だからあれはある一部の現象の研究であって
物質という存在の研究じゃないんです
リンゴ一個はすべてじゃないんです
いないはすべてじゃないんです
だから それは農業の他の分野でも
何か現象だけ 考えて新しい
例えば我々着ている服の色にしたっても
昔は植物の色で もう何とかして染めたんですけど
そんなに精密に様々な色を出すということはできなかったんです
で 今は色にすぎたら随分進んではいるんです
それから当然 昔の服っていうのは
色がある服っていうのは洗うとかなり危なく危ないんですよ
危険ですよ 例えば色を 3つぐらいある服があるとしても
それはまず糸を染めてから織ってみる
そうすると服になるとちゃんと色が分かれて
しっかり洗ったら全部ぐちゃーってなったり
もう何もどうにもならないことになっちゃうんで
これで困るんですね それで困るんだから
その糸を染めるという作業はどんな因果法則なのかと
どんどんどんどん研究して
落ちない色を作ったりする
だから服に例えば 6色ぐらいあっても
何の躊躇もなく洗えますよ
色は落ちない だから他の色と混ぜることはしません
だから結構発展なんですよ
では 服の色 服に色をつけるという分野はすごい発展しているんだからといって
因果法則を知っているのかと
物質のこと知ってるのは知らないんですね
具体的な現象の一つを知ることで十分だと思っているんですね
世界は これは終わりのない調べ方です
世間にある調べ方は終わりがない
リンゴを丸く 四角く 小さく
一口の大きさにいくらでもできますからね
じゃあ丸いボールのような丸いリンゴを作りましょう
いえ 四角いリンゴを作りましょうとかね
あるいはピラミッドみたいにちゃんと置いておけるリンゴを作りましょうとか
あるいはぽっと一口口に入れるブドウぐらいの大きさに作りましょうとか
平らのあの投げることでもできるリンゴを作りましょうとか
形にしたっても いくらでも無限にやります
味にしたっても同じことで
甘いだけのハチミツのように甘
いリンゴを作りましょうとかね
あるいは酸っぱい梅干しみたいに
梅干しの代わりにリンゴ使います
というリンゴの種類も開発できますよ
甘さがない 酸っぱいだけの
そんな難しいことじゃないんです
あるいはすごく苦いリンゴを作りましょうとかね
あるいは まあこれは無理でしょう
チョコレートの味のリンゴとかね
バニラの味のリンゴとかね
はい これからそういうリンゴを開発に頑張りましょうということも可能ですよ
だから単純にリンゴを開発したっても
終点がないんです どこまで行くのかと
はい どこまでやっているのかということになります
世界は 仏教は全体の一部ではなくて
全体の因縁を調べるんです
それでブッダの方法は全体の一部だけ知ってやろうではなくて
全体を知る方法はないのかと
何も漏れることなく一切を知る方法
また 何かを新たに作るためではなく
一切の現象が現れる絶対的な最終的な因縁パターンを発見するんです
それが仏教のやり方なんですね
仏教は何か このたくさんある世界にもう一つ一つゴミを作ってあげようとかね
そういうどうでもいいことに挑戦しないんです
なぜならば  2500年前のブッダの時代では
科学も何もなかったんですけど
人間がそれでも生きていたんですよ
何か欠けてたわけじゃないんですよ
当時当然電気がなかったでしょ
あれでみんな困っていたんですかね
インド 当時のインドの人間が大変だとか苦しんで経済不調に陥ったりして
株が下がったり 会社が倒産したり
こんなこと何もなかったんです
携帯でメールを送れなくなっちゃったりして
人生大変でしたとか何もなかったでしょうに
だから本来はこのみんなパターンに何か付け加えるんだけど
あれは一個一個いらんものなんです
必ず必要ということじゃないんです
欠かせないってことではないんです
携帯電話欠かせない 電気は欠かせない
コンピューター世界は欠かせないとかね
欠かせないものを作ったんじゃなくて
どうでもいいものを作ってそれに依存させるんですよ
だから一向に人間の道が楽にならないんです
両手ぶら下がって もうもう派手に振って歩く人に
あんたこれ持ちなさいと何か持たせる
そうすると その人がちょっと手を振る時はちょっと不便になるんですね
それで何も持ってない手を派手に振ったりすると
あんた一つ手空いていますから
これ持ちもう一つ持っちゃうと思うんです
そうすると その人はあれほど派手に手振れがないんだけど
まだ手を振っていくと
ああ ちょっとまた形変えましょうと
もう一つ もう一つ付けたりする
それで手を振っちゃうと
あの持ってる荷物は人にぶつけたりして
自分も怪我したりするんだから
次に怪我しないようにと
またまたもう一つ作ったりするんです
それで両手でいっぱい荷物を持って
その荷物で自分が怪我しないように
で 周りは怪我しないようにとかね
何やってるのかと それでカバンがどんどん重くなって重くなって持てなくなっちゃったんです
それでじゃあカバンにキャスターついたら引っ張っていけるんじゃないかなと
今はみんなキャスター付きのカバンを持ってるんです
で 次のステップはこのキャスター付きカバンは引っ張ってるのは便利ですけど
階段は困るでしょう 駅は階段ばっかりだからね
じゃあ見てください この
そのうち階段も何のことなく引っ張れるカバンを作るんです
あの業務用はありますよ
業務用のものはあります
階段も何のことなく もう下りたり上がったりすることはできます
まだ一般用になってないんです
それでキャスターは最初はあんまり良くなかったんですね
無理に引っ張らなくちゃいけなかったし
キャスターを壊れたりもするし
それでキャスターの機能はどんどん上がってきて
今はなんか指 1本でも引っ張ったらスッとくるんです
そうするとみんなの歩き方っていうのは
ものすごくダサくて気持ち悪くて行儀悪いんだから
もういい勝手に歩くんだからね
あの引っ張ってくること
人の体にぶつかるは 壁にぶつかるは
迷惑もいいところ そこでずっと看板書くんですね
駅で あのキャスター付きカバンを持ってる人々は
周りに迷惑にならないように気をつけてください
それか看板書いてあっても読めませんだ
携帯を見て歩くんだから
だからこれってのはすごい発展している世界ですね
見てください 一つも生命に関係ない
ものばっかりなんです
そこでどうなるのかというと
生命に関係あるものはどんどん弱くなっていくんですよ
空気が汚れているんです
酸素が必要でしょうに
で 今酸素を吸う時は ナイトロ酸化やらサルファーダイオキサイドやら
もうすいません 日本語の言葉を覚えてないんです
毒を吸わなくちゃいけないんですよ
そこで肺が弱くなっちゃうんです
で あの毒が血液に溶けるんですよ
しかし 研究施設で調べる濃度じゃないんです
しかし 細胞一個についてはすごい大変なダメージなんですよ
そこでえたい生活 病気が出てきて
私には病気があるんですけど
よくわからないって専門家が言うんです
その人たちもわからなくて
私はものすごく痛くて
もう動けなくなるんで
体が はっきりと神経発作みたいな感じですっごい痛くなって
もう倒れますけど それでももう 6時間
7時間ぐらい続けますよ
もうその痛みも でも優れた技術で調べてみると
究極の優れた技術で何もないと
あんた健康ですと どうしますかね
それが発展した世界なんです
優れた科学の世界なんです
昔の人間はもう想像もできない
天国のような世界だそうです
しかし 呼吸もできないと
まあ呼吸できなくなっても携帯あるんだからいいんじゃないんですかね
また 携帯で顔を見ながら喋れますから
すごいことでしょうね
そんなキャベツを汚染してやってもね
ジャガイモは汚染して
そんなことどうったことない
ただのキャベツでしょうと
で そういうわけで 本来のことを考えると
何かつけなくては生きていられないということは
ちょっと法則的にパターンから見ればおかしい
パターン知らないんだから
そんなことになったんだ
例えば犬には服はいらないでしょ
昔から今も犬には服はいらないし
犬は家がなくても生活できるしね
山の中でもどこでも 雨に濡れて濡れてこないと思ったら
どこかに隠れられる 隠れてそれで十分です
それで電気ストーブとか電気枕とか電気毛布とか犬には要りませんし
我々も地球の生命だからね
こういうプラスアルファで
このつけるもの アクセサリーが
命をかなり攻撃しているんです
ちょっとしたアクセサリーでも
いいわけじゃないんです
だから人間それ知らないんだから
とにかくあらゆるアクセサリーをつけて
つけてつけて すべてアクセサリーですよ
あの耳に鼻に首にかけることだけアクセサリーじゃないんです
こういうマイクロフォンもアクセサリーなんです
で カップもアクセサリーなんです
では 世の中でカップというものがなかったら
皆様は水を飲みなく飲めなくなって
脱水症で死ぬと思いますか？犬はそのままベロで飲みますね
猫もベロで飲みます 人間にはベロで飲めませんね
もしカップなかったらどうしますか？はい
皆様 本性は本性と言わない
本能はね どこまで残っているのかと
この質問でわかります
どこまで適応できる適者でしょうかと答えられる方がいます
もし世の中で 世の中でどこにもカップというものはない
しかし 動物も鳥も水は飲まなくちゃ生きていられません
人間は水を飲まなくちゃいけない
では 皆様どうします？人間
自然にいたならば どういうふうに水を飲むと思います
そう 手で取って飲むんです
それが答えです 人間にもちゃんとついてるんです
犬はベロで大丈夫です
もう大量に飲むんですよ
あのベロで ものすごい速くちゃんと運ぶ
人間には手があるんで
手で結構飲めます だからそこはあの本来のことを忘れてるんだから
このおかしいこと アメリカの映画なんかを見ると
このいろんな変な映画あるでしょ
もう文明から出て行って
もうどこも何もないところで
あっちゃこっちゃもう人もいないところで
もうそれすごくもう喉が渇いて
やっと水にたどり着いたら
しゃがんでそのまま飲むんですね
あの俳優さんが 水に口を入れて
やっぱりこの連中はもう自然からあまりにも本来の生き方からずれてるんだと
それはやりませんよ 本能があったら
川に口をつけて やりません
あんなことなく 手で選んで綺麗な水を選んで取って飲めるんです
口をつけて飲むと何か生き物でも入っちゃう可能性あります
動物は大丈夫ですけど
人間はいろいろ微生物が入っちゃうと困るんです
手で取ったらなんとなく本能的にこれ飲める
これ飲めないという本能が働くんです
だからもう我々いかに自然からずれているのかということで
それでこれ お釈迦様と比較するためにそこまで余計な話をしましたけど
なぜお釈迦様は物質の因果法則を知り尽くしたというならば
何一つも道具を作らなかったんですか？という問題なんです
それが道じゃない それで人間の生命は幸福にならない
大変な苦しみが生まれるだけ
だから人間暮らしましてやろうという目的はなかったんです
人間苦しませて もうもうで
自分が生きていきたいという恐ろしい気持ちがある人々は
すごいかっこいいブランド品物を作るんですね
作ってこれは限定品で 100点しか作ってないと宣伝するんです
値段はもう 30万円だと
それでテレビで 30 限定 100しかなかったら
金持ちで電話かけて手紙書いて売ればいいでしょうに
なんでテレビで宣伝するんですかね
限定 100しかなければ
何考えてるかわからないんだけど
人々を苦しめ 苦しませるんですよ 30
万円 ある人にしてたっても 30
万円でそれ買えるならば
もっと買わなくちゃいけないこといっぱいありますからね
買えないんですよ そうすると30万円持っているのにも
あんなくだらない もう例えばライターとかね
何か万年筆とかね 何かネクタイとかね
そんな程度のものをもう買えないでしょうに
だから精神的にいじめているんです
新たな苦しみを作っていけるるんです
あのマッキントッシュ会社がね
あのコンピューターを作って
もうまあ20万あたりのもうもっと仕方ない値段で売ってはいますけど
横にもう一つコンピューターをつけておくんです
あれは本体だけ50万円です
それでメモリやら必要なハードディスクとかつけちゃうと
ハードディスクも特別な
もので  10万ぐらいかかります
メモリはもう一時はもうもしかすると 2万
3万円で これ大量に必要なんです
だから全部揃っちゃうともう１３０万円ぐらいになるんです
CPU は 4つ入れたりして
それは側に置いておくんですね
あれって何なのかと ただ人を苦しませるだけ
もう若い男っていうのは
もう機械買う場合は一番いいものを買いたいんですよ
別に仕事があってもなくても気分で
だからいいものを買いたいということも余計で苦しみなんですけど
その上にあの機械を側に置いておくんだから
で 中身はほとんど聞いたんですよ
もうノートの場合は全部中見て
これもこれも同じ で 私は店にちょっと来てくださいと
私は今ノートを調べてますけど
キントスのね このノートは 12万円で
まあこれぐらい能力があって
これも同じハードディスクの容量も CPU のスピードももうグラフィックカードも全部同じですよ
なんでこれは 25万円ですかね？とか
あ それは中身は全然違いますねとか
それで答えなんです 何が違いますかと
まあいろいろ違います
だからあれっていろんな心理学的なね
いろんな工夫して人をいじめるんですよ
向こうの狙いは  10万円持ってる人はもう工夫して友達からもちょこちょことお金借りて
15万円持って店に行ったら
その人徹底的にいじめて 20万円のものを買わせてやるぞってことなんです
あの5万円も借りてるのに
そういうことで 今我々現代人が
あのあんまりにも苦しんでるんだけど
それに気づきさえもしないんですね
でも苦しみの結果あるんだからね
いったい知らない病気にかかるわ
病気に病気なのに機械で発見できないわ
で 薬はないわ 薬飲んだら毒で
あの薬とこの薬と合わないとかね
もう的中する薬作るんですよ
それ作っちゃうと 他のもの何も飲んだらあかんと
といういろいろまあ苦しい世界が出てくる
これはこのアクセサリー
因果法則はちょこちょことなめてアクセサリーを作るんです
本来いらないもの しかし
昔から今まで鳥たちは何のアクセサリーもなく生きているんです
いらないんですね ゴキブリっていうのは人間よりすごい昔からいるでしょ
ゴキブリやら蜘蛛やら
もうたまたま恐竜の時代から見る動物見るでしょう
アクセサリーつけてみて下さい
どうなるのかと 大変苦しむ羽目になるんですよ
犬と同じですね 犬に服を着せたりしてね
あの服はすごく高いんですよ
高いんだけど 服着させたところで気持ち悪いというと
ものすごいかわいい美しい犬なのに
突然すごい気持ち悪い存在になっちゃうんです
だから飼い主がもう頭があれだから
もうマインドコントロールというか
イカれてるんだから それが可愛いと見えるんですね
残念ながら私は知ってる人々の中でそういうことをやっている人がいないんだけど
もしいたならば一回でやめると思います
私はそれに何か言いますからね
あんたの人すごいかわいいでしょうと
でもこの服を着かせちゃったところで
最低最悪気持ち悪いんだと
触りたくもないんだと
でも服を脱がして裸にすると
これすっごいかわいいんだよ
と言いたいんだけど 誰もいないんですね
はい だからお釈迦様はやっぱり人の苦しみをなくすために因果法則を発見したんです
だから仏教は道具作りません
この観察の仕方には終わり
知り尽くす終了ということはありますがある
仏教の観察というのは
全体的にすべてのもののパターンを発見したんだから
もう終わったんです だから落ち着けるんですよ
知る 知るべきものは知り終えたと
これどれほど楽しいと思いますかね
我々は勉強すればするほど惨めになるでしょ
もっとあるんだ もっとあるんだと
勉強しない人は何もしないんだから落ち着いていますけど
勉強するともう知るところより知らないところの方がすごいんだから
もう苦しいんです そこで知り終えたと言えるならば
もうそれこそ幸福なんです
はい 信仰と迷信の仕事
現代人 科学研究者は心
知識 知る 考える 生きる機能
全部動義語です を信仰の世界に委託しているんです
現代人が心については
それは信仰の世界であると
あなた方はやってくださいと
因果法則だから あなた方やれなんて私が言いたいんだけど
信仰に委託しているんです
理性人だと空自慢しつつ
心については聖書する類の話に従う
どんな立派な科学者であれ
我々理性人でと空自慢していますけど
心のことになると すぐ聖書類の本を開けて引用するんで
堂々と これなんだこれはと
何の研究もしないんです
現代知識ではいまだに洗練された心の科学はないんです
だから物質はいじっていじってアクセサリーは作る
仏教は心の科学 心を研究する方法論は科学者にはないが
ブッダにあったのです
一切を知り尽くすという立場で観察した結果
心も知り尽くしたのです
終わったのです 物質のことをブッダが知り尽くしたし
心の科学です 仏教は心も知り尽くしたんです
それについて現代人は新しいものを組み立てることと同じく
完全たる境地 因縁を乗り越えた境地を提案して
また具体的に発明してあるのです
ん？ちょっと間違ってるみたい
ああはい 違った ただし
でお釈迦 現代人がやっていることと同じことなんです
お釈迦様も心の科学の場合は組み立てて新しいものを作っちゃったんです
物質の場合は何も作らなかったんです
心が命だから 命が苦しみたくはないんです
それで心の科学を知り尽くして組み立てたんです
新しい心 それには因縁を
乗り越えた境地 因縁に入っている間はものすごくダラダラして
もうガタガタして一時的ですぐ消える
当てにならない 現象というのは当てにならない
すぐ消えますから 皆さんの若さと同じなんです
あっという間に消えちゃいます
若いと自慢したっても
美しいと自慢したっても
何年でしょうかと だからそういうものは当てにならないんです
どんなものも なぜならば因果法則だからなんです
だったら因果法則を乗り越えるしかないんだと
いうことで 因果法則を乗り越えた境地を設定しています
そこは新しくお釈迦様が組み立てて
その状況になる方法を教えて
それでももう 具体的な発明ですね
それはもうブッダの具体的な発明なんです
まあそれは悟りのことですけど
仏教の悟りはこの世の中にあるものじゃないんです
因縁を乗り越えるんです
乗り越えるとあるんです
この場合も終わり 終了ということは成り立つのです
因縁を超えたら いわゆるパターンを超えたら終了です
問題は解脱を何かの工場で大量生産は不可能なことです
俗世間やっているものは大量生産できますけど
部品組み立 組み立ては解脱はそう大量生産できません
商品として売ることもできません
個がこの心を完成することが唯一の方法です
一人一人の人が自分の心を完成させるんです
だから それは一人一人の仕事になるんです
だから 工場で残念ながら解脱は作れません
しかし 挑戦者には多数の成功者のことを実例として出すんです
それでお釈迦様がやる手段は
そんなこと言ったってできると疑問を持っちゃうと実例出すんです
ほら こういう人を見てください
こういう人を見てください
100人でも見なさい
200人でも見なさい
500人でも見なさいと
みんな完成していますよと
じゃああんたもやりなさいよと
知識人がバラモンの知識人が
話はうまいんだけどね
あなたの あなたが推薦する境地も
まあ論理的にはすごいと思いますけど
しかし これは実践的には成り立たんでしょうと
言うと お釈迦様 この人
知識の一流のバラモン人でしょ
全然学校にも行ったこともない
文字も読めない 何も学んだことのない不可触民族の誰かに
あのね あんたこの人知ってる？何々カーストの人ですけど
元は 今聖者ですよと そうすると黙って黙るしかないんです
そういうことも一つの科学的なアプローチなんです
方法は正しいかということは
いろんな人がそこを実行して結果を出すことなんです
これはサンガの組織なんですね
サンガという仏法僧のサンガという
サンケーの場合は これはキリスト教からパクったものじゃないんですよ
三身論は あの仏教は初めですからね 3
つに構成しているサンガというシステムが
仏教にはどうしても欠かせないんですね
サンガという概念がこの成功者のグループなんです
だからたくさん成功者がいるならば
私個人にも実践できるということになるんです
次に心の科学と宗教 それでちょっと終わったら休憩に入ります
宗教には救いと信仰という概念があります
救っていただくのです
無条件で信仰するのです
これは心が不完全 不完全で固定していて
絶対変わらない 変えないという前提の上に成り立つのです
宗教の救ってもらう あるいは信仰するということになると
その人が心は不完全で固定しているんだと
変わらないし変えないしと思わなくてはならないんです
でなきゃ信仰成り立ちませんよ
自分一人でも天国に行けるならば
神を信仰する必要ないでしょう
心の科学と正反対の道です
だから仏教は宗教の道とは正反対の道です
これで科学の方法論を全部使ってますけど
科学ともものすごい違う道なんです
はい それで休憩に入ります
もう時間はないんですけどね